[Música]
bienvenidos una semana más a medio
ambiente desde casa en france 24
iniciamos hablando de videojuegos
más
es que no sabemos
[Música]
en su agencia
este es el trailer de reset a reiniciar
la tierra en español
el videojuego lanzado en febrero por el
programa de medio ambiente de las
naciones unidas para concientizar sobre
la importancia de la conservación de la
capa de ozono tres adolescentes
knox siguen y terrance son los
encargados de buscar una solución al
virus grow crece en español que ha
reducido la esperanza de vida a menos de
30 años en una historia que se
desarrolla en el año 2000 84 en un
planeta post apocalíptico el mensaje del
juego es mostrar y dar esperanza de que
cuando el mundo se une para lograr
objetivos concisos sobre la salud del
planeta y la de los humanos esto se
logra
the young generation creo que es
importante que las nuevas generaciones
se den cuenta de que pueden marcar la
diferencia pueden ser el cambio
pueden generar cambios incluso si
algunos de los problemas ambientales a
los que nos enfrentamos actualmente
puedan parecer insuperables
en mans go el problema de la destrucción
del ozono se logró controlar en 1985
durante la convención de viena cuando la
humanidad se unió para frenar el
crecimiento del agujero en la capa que
nos protege de los rayos ultravioleta
del sol de esta convención surgió el
protocolo de montreal firmado dos años
después este que entró en vigor en 1989
regula las sustancias que agotan la capa
de ozono y que en su mayoría son además
potentes gases de efecto invernadero su
implementación consiguió la erradicación
progresiva del 98 6% de estas sustancias
sin embargo según la onu la lucha no ha
terminado y su conservación no es un
juego
son jóvenes en país incluso con el
protocolo de montreal en marcha la
historia del agujero de ozono no ha
terminado el agujero en la capa de ozono
no está arreglado incluso asumiendo que
todos cumplan con el protocolo de
montreal tendrán que pasar otros 30 años
aproximadamente para que los hoyos se
recupere a los niveles anteriores a 1989
así que también queremos inculcar la
noción de que con respecto al protocolo
de montreal y a la historia del agujero
en la capa de eso no tenemos que seguir
atentos la historia sigue en desarrollo
el juego rise theres cuyo lema es un
ozono un planeta una oportunidad está
disponible para su descarga en todos los
teléfonos iphone o android y de las
capas más altas del planeta vamos ahora
de vuelta a la superficie terrestre para
ver las fotos que recibieron más votos
en el premio popular a fotógrafo del año
organizado por el museo de historia
natural de londres entre las cuatro
finalistas que obtuvieron mención
especial está el último adiós que
refleja los momentos finales de vida de
sudán el último rinoceronte blanco del
norte macho que existía en el planeta y
que murió en marzo de 2018 la imagen
tomada por la estadounidense amy vita le
muestra al rinoceronte junto a su
cuidador en la reserva natural o el peje
está al norte de kenia otra foto que
recibió mención especial fue ésta
hecha por el británico andy y parkinson
en ella vemos como una liebre trata de
refugiarse del frío en escocia formando
un círculo casi perfecto la tercera foto
de las cuatro que fueron elogiadas fue
esta imagen tomada en wyoming eeuu por
guillermo estévez en la que vemos la
cara de preocupación de este perro que
se ve enfrentado a un enorme alce un
recordatorio de lo imponentes que
resultan los animales salvajes y antes
de revelar la foto ganadora veamos la
última de las que recibieron mención
especial una apacible imagen capturada
por el británico
anderson en la que vemos cómo esta
ardilla encontró refugio del frío y
descansa en un nido hecho dentro de una
caja que el fotógrafo había dejado en un
árbol precisamente con ese objetivo
y finalmente la imagen ganadora fue está
titulada bus fire o incendio forestal
hecha por el australiano robert irwin
durante los incendios en el estado de
queensland al noreste de australia a
comienzos del año pasado la foto que
muestra a partes iguales la devastación
del fuego y la belleza natural de la
zona fue hecha con un dron sobrevolando
la reserva de vida salvaje steve irb en
zona protegida a nombrada en honor al
reconocido conservacionista australiano
apodado el cazador de cocodrilos que
falleció tras ser picado por una
mantarraya en 2006 precisamente el
fotógrafo es su hijo que decidió seguir
la labor de su padre de conservación de
la naturaleza pero a través de la
fotografía y esta semana finalizamos el
programa hablando del gato larry el más
famoso del reino unido
larri cumplió 10 años en el número 10 de
downing street la residencia oficial de
los primeros ministros británicos su
título es el de jefe ratonero de la
oficina del gabinete un cargo que aunque
oficialmente sólo existe desde que llegó
larry ha desempeñado algo
gato desde comienzos del siglo 16 cuando
reinaba enrique octavo larry fue llevado
al famoso edificio en 2011 desde un
refugio para gatos y perros donde fue
elegido entre los demás felinos por sus
aptitudes para cazar ratones en la
página web oficial de la residencia
ministerial le atribuyen a la red las
siguientes funciones diarias además de
cazador de roedores le da la bienvenida
a los invitados y prueba que muebles son
los más cómodos para echarse una siesta
con imágenes de larry el gato me despido
sigan con más en france 24 y france24
puntocom